First Lady Melania Trump is learning
about a painful part of America's
history on her first full day in Africa
this morning she toured a castle that
house slaves awaiting transport across
the Atlantic mrs. Trump said she will
never forget the vision visit to the
island of Ghana this is her first solo
foreign trip as first lady and it will
take her to four African countries
Debora patta is following the tour from
Johannesburg South Africa
Deborah good morning good morning
Melania Trump for nation tour to Africa
fun as the traditional path of a
goodwill gesture by the first lady but
in the country she is visiting many
people are saying she will have to
overcome the baggage of her husband's
belittling comments about the continent
earlier this year Melania Trump arrived
on her outreach to Africa as part of her
be based campaign she was welcomed in
colorful style and greeted by Ghana's
first lady Rebecca ikawa
adore Africa is well-traveled terrain
for us first ladies girls who are not
being uneducated
Michelle Obama focused on empowering
young girls through leadership and
education Hillary Clinton highlighted us
support for African democracy educated
women and Dora Bush made many trips to
the continent in support of her HIV and
AIDS projects Laura Bush's former chief
of staff Anita McBride said often they
were more popular than their husbands
when traveling abroad well this is a
perfect role for a First Lady of the
United States to really be a softening
tone or a gentler tone and an to build
bridges mending those bridges might well
be the unspoken subtext of Melania
Trump's African tour as well as her
husband's disparaging remarks about the
region many of her planned events
highlight programs funded by US aid even
though the Trump administration has
proposed cuts to the organization's
budget and they appear to be at odds
with the president's overall policies
but it's important that she try and
and do what she can to sort of change
that impression as much as you can there
are still more opportunities for the
first lady to repair the relationship
with Africa with stops ahead in Malawi
tenure and Egypt John Deborah pate in
Johannesburg thanks